beware of blade from the minute Marvel
Studios made their San Diego comic-con
announcement that moonlight and true
detective star Maher Sheila alley would
be leading a reboot of the
groundbreaking comic-book movie blade
fans have wondered what alley might look
like all done up as a legendary Vampire
Killer well they're in luck
Photoshop wizard and well-known Marvel
fan boss logic recently tried his hand
at creating an edit of Ally's blade that
would further boost hype for the film
and the end product has done that and
more shared on his Instagram page
boss logics vision of aalia's blade sees
the actor wielding a shotgun in one hand
and blades signature acid-etched sword
and the other and features a red tinted
version of his iconic sunglasses fans on
social media are going mad for this
intense red and black version of blade
with countless users praising boss
logics work on Instagram
boss logic may have had some help in
creating this edit though as it looks
like he used a promotional photo of
original blade actor Wesley Snipes as
the basis for the image then
superimposed all these head over Snipes
and made some clever tweaks still boss
logics edits are on point and his
considerable photoshop skills have
gifted fans a pic that's all kinds of
sleek and spooky just as blade should be
worse things out tonight than man
like what like me but boss logic is far
from the first person to create a work
of fanart that imagines what blade could
look like when he makes his Marvel
Cinematic Universe debut 1 artists
Instagram schooled er ver has created a
series of gorgeous concept illustrations
of ollies blade with fangs a killer
costume and round frame glasses while
another Photoshop expert apex forum
imagines Ally's blade as having glowing
red eyes heavy bulletproof armor and two
swords tucked in a pack on his back heck
this particular piece of blade art isn't
even the first boss logic has made five
months before Marvel announced the blade
reboot and confirmed that Ali would be
starring in the lead role
boss logic created an edit that featured
a leas blade with heavy tattoos fangs
reflective sunglasses and his sword
sheathed in between his shoulders
clearly almost everyone is stoked out of
their minds that Ali is playing blade in
the upcoming Marvel reboot for a short
while however there was actually some
controversy surrounding Ali's casting
but only because fans of 1998's blade
were hoping that og actor Snipes would
have some sort of involvement in the new
film luckily this wave of criticism died
down when Snipes himself came forward to
comment on the project and Ali's casting
Snipes shared in a statement obtained by
comicbook.com that he understands why
Marvel casts Talia's blade and not him
it's just the nature of show business he
also heaped praise on Ali's suggesting
that if anyone was going to follow in
his footsteps and take over the blade
mantle Snipes would want it to be him
Snipes said although the news comes as a
surprise it's all good such is the
business of entertainments much peace to
the MCU crew always a fan
congratulations and Salaam to marshal
Ali a beautiful and talented artist
whose expressions I look forward to
experiencing for many years to come
inshallah we will some day work together
welcome to the daywalker clique fans are
practically chomping at the bit to see
all these iteration of blade up on the
big screen and while this edit by boss
logic might help satisfy that craving
nothing will compare to the real thing
since Marvel hasn't yet offered up a
release date for their Blade reboot
however boss logics fan art will have to
tide everyone over for now check out one
of our newest videos right here
us even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]